how much would it cost to be a wizard at
Hogwarts like Harry Potter let's find
out
you just got your acceptance letter to
Hogwarts and you're extremely excited
but you need to get the checkbook out
because it's going to be pricey if
you're a true Potter head you know that
JK Rowling has declared that Hogwarts
tuition is free because the Ministry of
Magic covers the cost so the 7 years you
will spend studying at Hogwarts will be
completely free unlike my education
Hogwarts tuitions zero dollars you're
going to need to get some wizards
school supplies and there's no better
place than the theme park gift shop I
mean Diagon Alley according to the
Hogwarts acceptance letter students are
required to buy many things ranging from
a winter cloak to a pewter cauldron
these items cause 1031 dollars do you
want a magical pet most bird breeders
will charge about $250 for an owl
adoption add on some veterinarian cost
food a nice cage we get to $400 but how
about transportation go to platform 9
and 3/4 and board the Hogwarts Express
the average train ride going that
distance in England is about $150 now
that you're living at Hogwarts you'll
want to dive into some of the local
activities like Quidditch to play this
awesome game you need your own equipment
a broom some personal goggles and a pair
of socks the rest is mostly covered by
Hogwarts Quidditch $550.00 wizards break
a lot of things in their time at
Hogwarts unfortunately they break a lot
of expensive things costs of damages six
million nine hundred forty five thousand
thirty-five dollars and at the end of a
long stressful day of fighting evil
you're going to want to go to the local
pub and have a delicious butter beer
with your friends one round of butter
beers ten dollars to calculate the grand
total we have to consider that you spend
seven years at Hogwarts in the inflation
value the British Pound changes over
those seven years so converted into
wizard money then converted back into
dollars to factor in structural
macroeconomics bank loan fees national
fiscal policies now stuff like that it
gets us to fifteen million three hundred
sixty thousand one hundred twenty two
dollars if you want to afford it all
better be friendly with those goblins
over at Gringotts Bank or talk to JK
Rowling she is loaded
you